kennst du schon diese Videos die
robotaxis in den USA zeigen die
amerikanischen Unternehmen wie waymo
oder Cruise setzen auf voll
automatisiertes fahren auf Level 4 dabei
gibt es stark limitierte Gebiete für
ihre robotaxis also nur einzelne
Stadtgebiete die vorher aufwendig
kartografiert wurden aber selbst in
diesen Gebieten bleiben die Autos oft
stecken und das Wetter bleibt eine
Herausforderung und was ist im Autoland
Deutschland deutsche Hersteller
konzentrieren sich eher auf Level 2 und
3 mit Features wie stauassistenten oder
automatisiertem fahren auf der Autobahn
obwohl in Deutschland das W 3 fahren auf
der Autobahn mit bis zu 130 km/h erlaubt
ist hat sich bisher kein Hersteller
getraut das in seine Autos einzubauen
woran das liegt das haben wir Experten
in diesem Video gefragt abonniert gerne
für mehr